we are asked how much time has passed
from the time on the left so right over
here to the time on the right which we
see right over here and they say that
the time passed is less than 12 hours so
like always pause this video and see if
you can answer that on your own before
we work on this together
all right
so
first i just want to figure out what
time is being told by each of these
clock faces so let's go here on the left
so the first thing i'm going to do is
look at the hour hand and we can see
that the hour hand has gone a little bit
past six
so it's going to be six something
six something and then to figure out
what the minutes are
i can look at the minute hand right over
here and say well how far has it gone in
minutes
and i like to count by fives because we
know when we go from 12 on the clock to
1 that actually 1 two three four five
minutes have gone by in fact between any
two numbers it's five minutes so we go 5
10
15 20 25 30 35
40 and then 41 42 43 that's where it's
pointing so it's 643 is where we're
starting and then where we're ending
let's see the hour hand is a little bit
past 9. you can see it's past nine
and so it's not necessarily what it's
closest to it's what it's passed so even
if the hour hand was like there even if
it was closer to 10 but not quite at 10
you would say okay it's going to be 9
something it's past nine
and so and only if it got to 10 or past
10 then you would say it's 10 something
so this is going to be 9 something and
to figure out what that something is
once again we start here we can count by
5s 5 minutes 10 minutes and then we got
we have one more we get to 11 minutes so
it's 9
11.
and they tell us that this is less than
12 hours apart so it's not like 6 43
in one day at maybe at night and then 9
11 the next morning this is maybe the
same morning or the same evening and so
we can set up a timeline here so let's
set up a timeline
and so let's see we
the six
six is the sixth hour is going to be
important so that's six o'clock and
let's see maybe we want to go all the
way to 10 o'clock
so that we go beyond 9 11. and so then
we could say let's see we'll have two 7
8 9 i just want to get my spacing right
so let's say that this is 7 o'clock
right over here
this is
eight o'clock
right over there and then that is nine
o'clock right over there it's not going
to be a perfect drawing but this is
pretty close and so see we are starting
at 6 43
is going to be let's see it's going to
be roughly and i just have to say
roughly it's going to be right over
there that's where we are starting and
then 911 is going to be roughly right
over there so that is when we are ending
so how much time has gone by
well to go from 6 43 to 7 o'clock how
many minutes is that
well
to go from 43 minutes to 60 minutes you
have to add 17 minutes so this right
over here
that is 17
minutes i'll just write it out
and then we can see we have another two
hours that goes by from seven o'clock to
nine o'clock so then that's two hours
and then to go from nine o'clock to 9 11
what is going on well that's going to be
another 11 minutes 11
minutes so how much time has happened
it's going to be 17 minutes plus 2 hours
plus 11 minutes
well i find it a little bit easier just
think about the minutes first so if i
add 17 minutes to 11 minutes 17 plus 11
is 28 i can do that on the side if you
want to see it
seven plus one is eight one plus one is
two
so we are going to have a total of two
hours and twenty eight minutes and i
could write it that way two hours
two hours
and 28
minutes
and we are done